Welcome everybody to another Dune Paul. Sorry, we weren't live last week, but back at it again.
I hope everybody is staying warm in there dealing with the crazy weather we're having
across the whole United States. We pray for each other. We know that we're all on God's hands
we need to stay in prayer for one another and for ourselves and be dependent upon him as much as
possible. Okay, so for those that are new to all of this reminder you can submit your questions
on the member's site. If oh good as I didn't get a question submitted in time but I still want to get
an answer go ahead and just start chatting it in right now in the chat box. Everybody enters this
a Zoom call muted. If you do want to verbalize your question I ask that you just wait till we finish all
these that were already submitted and I'll get to the chat ones usually at the end as well. All right,
let's get started with the questions. Oh, last announcement. Always remember on the member's home page
look for announcements. Let's jump into the questions. Your first question. If there is a product that
someone else recommended that I take is that okay. Okay, remember this is your choice in your
cancer care. We're not my way or the highway type clinic. I only ask that you run it by me.
I've had people that maybe don't watch the Zoom calls at all. Don't look at our website at all
and then I find out after I haven't spoken to them for a long long time that they're taking things
that they really shouldn't take like glutathione or methylated nutrients or something like that.
And it was recommended by a naturopath or their car proctor or something who doesn't understand
the nuances of cancer. And so I don't want you taking things that you shouldn't take. Of course you
could do whatever you want to do, but at least I want to give you the right advice. I mean you're part
of our clinic and we want to take care of you. So whereas in one aspect you could do whatever you
want to do. Another aspect is I feel it's a shame if you don't at least get our advice whether
you feel like God's leading you in a different direction or not. I want you to be obedient to him
ultimately, but I certainly don't want you making a decision based upon fear or pressure,
peer pressure or pressure from another practitioner who's got a very, very strong personality and
telling you, oh my gosh, you should be taking glutathione. You have cancer. Well, then if they
said that phrase, then it's obvious they know nothing about cancer and they shouldn't be giving you
advice, period, let alone giving any cancer patient advice, but at least if you do get
recommended supplements from another practitioner, my suggestion is you say, I get a way to buy it
and I'll take a picture of it and I'll send it to Dr. Cutters and run it by him if he thinks it's okay
then or if I would pray about it and I feel like this is exactly what I'm supposed to shake regardless
of what other what Dr. Cutters says, then do so, but don't be pressured into doing anything,
even by your oncologist, don't let anybody pressure you into anything, don't let me pressure you into
anything, make the decisions, we're called to use wisdom, so we're called to seek wisdom and wisdom
is applied knowledge, so you know I study I'm studying constantly to better serve you and but
but wisdom is also applied knowledge that the Holy Spirit can apply to our hearts too, so
it's not just applied by other people and then we're taking that information and trying to apply it
to everyday life, but it's information that is going to be best suited for us, so we want to have
peace about all our decisions that we make, but we want to base them on intelligence, God has desired
us to use the brain that he's given us and use the resources that he's given us, he's called some
to be apostles, some to be teachers, some to be prophets, some to be evangelists, etc, and he's called
some to be you know we put ourselves under people like doctors to help us guide us because we can't
know everything, you know I don't try to do Masonary work when that's not my specialty,
okay fair I do try to do Masonary work even if it's not my specialty, but that's another story,
so we want to utilize the gifts that we have and utilize other people's gifts and then
be prayed about it and ask God for wisdom and peace about all our decision making processes, so
all I ask is that if you're you're getting recommendations from somebody else, you just run it by me
and we'll talk about it, okay next question, what is the warranty on the bulb, is it easy to break?
there is no warranty on the bulb and everybody who's received the bulb has got this little sheet of
paper that says there's no warranty on the bulb and it is easy to break, within means, so I've had
my bulb for years and I've never broken, I just got an email from a patient who broke the end
off the bulb off the cord and said do I have to is this easy to fix or do I have should I just buy
a new bulb, well if it's the end that plugs into the P220 machine or the thrift machine that is
relatively easy to repair, so I told him to send it back to me, I'll repair it, there'll be a fee
for that repair and it's nominal and I'll send it back to you and you'll have a bulb that works just
fine, if the cord that attaches to the bulb part of it itself comes out or dislodges that is not
repairable, remember by definition a Tesla tube is a gas-filled tube, so within that glass tube
that's inside the plexiglass protective tube in that glass tube is a gas and if the wire that
attaches to it becomes dislodged or cracks off the gas will dissipate and the tube is a loss and
you have to throw it away, it's not repairable, I can't even send it back to the tube manufacturer to
repair it, it's the cost the same as getting a new bulb, so remember there's no markup on the
bulb, so the bulbs are the cost, that's what I pay for them, that were not making anything off the
bulb, so there's no warranty, so isn't easy to break, if you bulk it just right, we need the end of
the bulb where the wires connect to the inside that plastic tube, if you just bonked it against your
headboard or you fell on the ground and it hit just wrong, then yes, it can easily break that
connection and the tube is a loss, so I've had people that have had bulbs for 15 years and
they just never hit it wrong, and I've had people that have had it for a couple of months,
and I'm not in your home, I don't know how your home operates, I don't know,
it can be just some weird thing that you're just banging against the headboard or
or it fell on the ground and it fell just wrong, so there's no warranty, so if the bulb stops working,
you know, you can set it back to us and I can check to see if it is just the connection, if it's
at the connection where the wires connect to the right machine, that is always repairable, and I've
repaired that on several people over the years, lots of people over the years, that's very repairable,
if it's at the connection where the wires connect to the bulb itself, then that's not repairable,
so that the gas will leak out and it's a loss, if the plexiglass cracks, let's say you dropped the bulb
and it cracked the plexiglass, you have a tile floor, let's say you're five-year-old grabbed it
banged it super hard against the edge of a table and it cracked the plexiglass, but the bulb still works,
the plexiglass is just a protective sheet, that means nothing, so if the plexiglass
is cracked or busted, it doesn't even, it doesn't even matter, as long as the bulb is working,
so in the crystal bulbs, you'll have some of the crystals that will fall off as you move it and stuff
like that, that's normal, it's just don't worry about it, I've had people with very old crystal bulbs
where patches of crystal fall off, that's okay too, it doesn't need to have crystals on it, that's an
added feature, so I remember when there was no crystal bulbs, it was simply the bulb,
that's fine, the crystals just give a different delicacy of the frequencies to be able to hit just,
it's just add, it's just an add-on, it's not necessary, I had for years I had a bulb that was not a
crystal bulb, that's what I used for my cancer was a true rife bulb that was not a crystal bulb,
so but yes if you just hit the bulb just wrong, especially you're going to be hitting the ends
of the bulb itself, would be just wrong, the bulb could lose its gas and then it's it's
toasted, it's done, but the wires are usually easy to fix if it's at the end and that's fixable,
so you do have to be very very careful with your bulb, this is a delicate piece of equipment
so you have to be careful with it, that's question after having cancer surgery and taking supplements,
I seem to have a persistent post nasal drip that bothers me every morning and many evenings,
I never experienced this before my surgery, change of diet and taking supplements, I wash my nasal
cavity with salt and alcohol nasal wash and that helps with clearing the mucus, I also take your
clear histamine scavenger quite often and also benefit from that and benederald, I was just wondered if
there were other tests and protocols I should do and any other recommendations you have regarding
this, so if a person has persistent post nasal drip, persistent, that you're having persistent
inflammation in the nasal cavity, you think of things like you know a chronic sinus infection or
you think of polyps like I have or you think of things like allergies, so if you're helped by
a clear histamine scavenger then you start thinking more and benederald, well benederald could help
sinus infection, the symptoms of sinus infection too, but with clear histamine scavenger helping you
think more on the side of possible allergies, so then you think well this is right after surgery,
what would surgery do to as a precursor to stimulate an allergic reaction, well surgery
affects your body and in a way that creates a hyper growth response to try to
help your body heal post surgery and that is going to increase this, increase a hyper immune
hyper cytokine response in the process of healing post surgery, which in itself can spark an allergy
to something, so you could develop sensitivities and what I would think of if this is, if the
post nasal drip doesn't go seasonally, then you start thinking of a foodborne allergy, so might
have been something you were just eating after the surgery that now that you do your entire life with
no issues, and now you have a hypersensitivity too, so you have antibodies to the peptides of that food,
that's what I would think of, so the test that I would think of running would be the Cyrex
Array 10, to see do I have antibodies to foods that I'm eating all the time that I've ate my entire
life, and now I've developed antibodies to these things and I'm developing this allergic response
because of that, that would be my first step, is that we can rule out a chronic sinus infection,
you know, based upon the time, like the time, and it doesn't necessarily come and go when you're
not having other symptoms in an elevated white blood cell count, etc. So I would think that you've
developed antibodies, that's something that happens very common after surgery, and we could easily
find out if that's true, by riding a Cyrex Array 10, and if you might be shocked at something that
you're sensitive to, then how can I be sensitive to that, I hate that my entire life, well you didn't
because of the surgery now you've developed antibodies against that, it couldn't be, let's say,
if I didn't have surgery, let's use a different example here, I'm going to teach you in moment here,
I didn't have surgery, I changed my diet, well again, a change of diet, even if you're eating better food,
I never used to eat these things all the time, now I'm eating them, they're good for me, let's
let's just say salad, okay, or greens, or something like that, they're good for me, why am I,
if you have antibodies too, though, that thing, even a good food, you can have antibodies to
something that is really, really good for you, it doesn't make any difference if it's good for you,
or not good for you, antibodies to a food are going to develop a inflammatory response,
so it could be that you're eating things you didn't eat before, and you've developed antibodies
against those things, thirdly, let's say you didn't have surgery and you didn't change your diet,
and you just started taking supplements, and now you've developed this allergic type response,
could you be allergic to something you're taking, that's a possibility as well, I would first think
that it could be like a sensitivity to the capsules of the supplements, not so much what's in the
supplements itself, but if certain supplements help then that would kind of rule that out,
so I would go back to food sensitivities as my first differential diagnosis, and that would be
the first thing that I would look at, is that, that's what that's the thing I would look at,
so Cyrex array 10, you could just order it on the store if you want to talk to me,
you can schedule a time with me too, next question, I recently heard a segment of a researcher
talking about how oregano oil and black seed oil taken for 30 days could stop cancer,
they said this person mysteriously died after going public, just wondering if you have any thoughts
on oregano oil and black seed oil as a supplement, well I'll answer the second part first,
oregano oil is a great killer of viral infections, even bacterial infections,
black seed oil is a great killer of fungal infections, so they're both really good,
so I like them both as supplements, are there any negatives to taking them? If you have an auto-immune
disorder, oregano oil stimulates an immune response and can make that worse,
black seed oil, no it doesn't, if you have cancer and no real-known auto-immune issue that you're
dealing with, you don't have rheumatoid arthritis or something like that, then your safe taking those
just as a trial thing, but to comment in the first part, a researcher talking about how oregano oil
and black seed oil taken for 30 days could be the killer of cancer, you're just going to be
careful of stuff like that, it's just nonsense, you see that all over, and then the guy mysteriously
died, oh right, I know who comes up with this stuff, I mean I'm not saying anything bad about this
comment, this is the kind of things that drive me up the wall with Instagram and Facebook,
there's a guy would be willing to bet whoever published this is selling oregano oil and black seed oil,
I'm sorry, but I'm mr cynical I guess, but it's, these are the kind of things that I think give
alternative care a black eye because nothing is like this miracle cure, there's no, we're gonna stop
looking for miracle cures, we gotta start looking at, honestly we gotta start looking at Jesus Christ
as our, as our savior and he gives us wisdom like we talked about earlier and he gives us knowledge to
use, but and I know you're whoever has asked this question isn't buying it into this, but we gotta
understand the general public does and and that's sad because we look to things other than Christ and
that bothers me, and I don't like it that to me if I was if I was an oncologist seed something like
this, I would think that all natural doctors are a bunch of absolute quacks and and and that's not true
and and and and this kind of thing does give that a black eye, can a regular oil and black seed oil
be good for somebody with cancer, why sure, but you see these all the time that this
cures cancer, this and this and the person died after going public about this, oh come on, I mean
I have gone public with 2000 blog posts about different things that can help people with cancer
and nobody's killed me for that why would they, I mean it's kind of silly, but certainly you could
try this there's there's no harm in this regular L has no downside for cancer, nor does black
seed oil have downside for cancer, so these are tribal supplements if you feel like God is lady you
by all means you can give it a try. Next question, I was surprised to see that the rife spikes
by EMF meter, I know rife uses EMFs that are supposed to be safe but I was surprised to see my
meter spike red is this normal is my meter bad, if my meter is spiking red for safe rife EMFs
then how could I trust what my meter tells me I'm confused about this, well I don't know what meter
you're using it even if you piped it on the chat and said you're using XYZ meter, I'm not ultra familiar
with each meter so I wouldn't be able to help that wouldn't help me at all, but frequent the rife
is going to emit frequencies, so it is an EMF electromagnetic frequency that is harmful is a
frequency that is a higher range frequency much higher than your rife can produce, so the rife
the true rife and until your robot cannot produce frequencies that are in a dangerous
EMF you know the danger frequencies, so you don't have to worry about the rife producing, people have
asked me that a lot of the case review, I'm sensitive to EMFs will the rife make that worse, the rife
can't produce frequencies in the hertz level high enough, it has to be in the killer hertz level
the rife only goes the true rife only goes to 12,000 hertz that the until your robot only goes to
30,000 hertz that's all you need for healing, those are healing frequencies the killer hertz and
the megahertz frequencies are the EMF frequencies that are dangerous, so you you can't hurt yourself with
EMFs, the EMFs and EMF is electromagnetic frequency, so the rife is producing electromagnetic
frequencies, but not in a range that is the harmful EMF frequencies, have you reached
scalar energy for healing, there are many companies making equipment that you think is good,
spooky two makes scalar wave generator that includes a mode for rife EMFs to run concurrent with
the scalar, so scalar energy is kind of an alternative term, so it encompasses, it really means you're
using light frequencies, is what scalar energy means, now there's different companies and different
people to talk about scalar energy in a different way, they're defining that term a little bit
differently, but I don't use the term scalar energy because it isn't a scientific
physics term, so it's I don't that's why I don't use that term, but it is a selling point in
different rife circles, oh you have to use scalar energy, well what is scalar energy, so you're
you want to use light frequencies, that's my opinion, so again different modes of healing
like a pulsed electromagnetic field therapy, a PEMF, that's only using electrical frequencies,
it's not using light frequencies, and it's in a very specific range, a PEMF unit, most PEMF units
you can't even change the frequency range, so hopefully that helped answer your question,
you want to use light frequency to help kill pathogens and kill cancer cells, electrical frequency
isn't really going to do that at all, so scalar energy is another term for light frequencies,
and other companies may use that term differently because it's not maybe adequately defined
because it isn't a scientific term in itself, hopefully that helps.
Next question, I'm thinking of trying these homeopathic drops called slender ease to help with
10 to 15 pound weight gain from hormone blockers and menopause and fatigue,
the many other things that come with menopause, the ingredients are ammonium bromantum,
I'm not going to read all these homeopathic names, and it has, so every all these homeopaths,
these are all homeopaths, if this is a product, eat it, not a homeopath,
then I would not approve of that, so this is methylcobalib, it sounds like the homeopaths
in here, and then these are supplements, so these are, this is a homeopath, Cali, Phosphorochum,
these are all homeopaths here, so understand homeopathy, homeopath is using a frequency
of a substance to stimulate your body in traditional homeopathy, it's to stimulate your body
to heal something, and there's different forms of homeopathy, you may take like, okay, you
using our radiation homeopath or radialgen homeopath, that's the homeopath of radium to help pull
radiation out of your body, or if you're going to take mercury as a homeopath, you're using the
frequency of mercury to stimulate your body to release mercury and to get mercury out of your body,
that's how homeopaths work, can you hurt yourself with homeopaths?
You could have a herx type reaction because you're dumping toxins, but that's really about it,
you're not going to really, you can't really hurt yourself with the homeopath other than that,
what you can, I mean, that can be harmful, you can feel sick, but you're not going to, you know,
do dare, you're not going to, there's no leastal dose of a homeopath, whereas there's a leastal dose
of everything else, exactly homeopathy, so homeopath is the frequency of a substance,
okay, so it looks like these are homeopaths, I have no trouble with homeopaths,
so you can take homeopaths, no problems, these are not homeopaths, these are nutrients,
so methyl cobalamine is a methylated B12, Ashwagandha is a nutrient that can help call you,
it's an adaptogenic herb, so does rodiola, biotid is a nutrient, rose hips is a source of vitamin C,
so I guess I would have maybe a little bit of problem with that, but if it's just the rose hips,
then it's just a food-based vitamin C, so it's probably not a lot there, so I don't really have
problem with that, I just have problem with this, because this is a methyl cobalamine, so this is a
methylated substance that methylated B12 that you really don't want to have, and I don't
remember who asked this question, so I mean it might be different if the person is completely
doing great with their cancer, and this is a very, very low dose of methyl cobalamine, then I guess I
would, you know, when you're going to take it for a short period of time, I don't have problem with that,
but if it's a different person who is dealing with their active cancer right now, you don't want
those methyl groups, okay, hopefully that helps. The next question, can I do budwig cottage cheese and
flax seed, so this is the budwig protocol, if I'm told to limit dairy, we've had this question
about 2,000 times over the years, and the answer is if you ask the budwig people that they'll say,
oh, when you add flax seed to dairy, you change the properties of dairy, and it doesn't negatively
affect you anymore. Well, that is just not a good answer, because that is just not true, you know,
you can't change the protein in the dairy by adding flax seed to it, it's still going to have the
same components, still has the same peptides, it's still going to stimulate that mTOR pathway,
so that is, you know, whatever, regardless of what they tell you on the budwig, you know, website,
it's still a dairy product. Now, again, you know, if the person is like, I really feel like God
is leading me to do the budwig protocol, try this for a month, then by all means, you know,
override what I told you about dairy and do it, and if you feel like this is what God is telling you
to do, but if you just are grasping that straws because you read that somebody on Facebook used the
budwig protocol and it helped their cancer, then I, you know, no, I mean, you're not supposed to act
that way, we're not supposed to make decisions that way, in anything in life, are you supposed to
make decisions that way? So, by all means, you know, be praying about your decisions, and you're asking
me this question, I would say no, you know, you shouldn't do that, but by all means, you know, you
pray about it and do what God's telling you to do, that's more important. Next question, I'm
interested in ways to manage discomfort, mild pain while waiting for a diagnosis or waiting
for treatments to alleviate pain. Okay, so what are some good natural ways to deal with pain? Well,
so, you, uh, it's hard to answer this question because there's not really any good natural ways to
deal with pain that are going to really break the pain cycle. So, you can use anti-inflammatories,
high-dose curcumin, high-dose, you know, flavonoids, which is curcumin, Boswellia, Resveratrol,
Stiny Nettle, you know, rosemary, corseted, those things can help, especially for inflammatory type
pain, like a headache or inflammation of the arteries, they can be helpful. Stimulate the
parasympathetics can also be helpful. So, uh, parasympathetic exercises, you can go on the
membership site and look at parasympathetic exercises in sympathetic exercises to decrease
sympathetic, those can be very helpful. What's the number one parasympathetic exercise? coffee
enemas can be real helpful for pain because they're stimulating the parasympathetics so you're using
neurology to help decrease the pain. Other natural things that can help with pain is Arnica,
that can help with pain. CBD slightly can help with pain. THC, which is the, which is the
psychoactive form of the marijuana can be helpful for pain. Over the years, we've had people,
you know, smoke, uh, they don't want to cigarette and help with pain. I don't know, I've never
smoked a marijuana cigarette, so I'm not the person to ask about that. But we've had people
over the years at all, I smoked marijuana back when I was in high school, but that was 50 years ago,
I've never smoked sense and they smoke, you know, take a couple of puffs of a joy to it,
really helps with pain. I can't give you any testimony to that, but that's a possibility.
Some people could, you know, you could get THC and, um, in liquid form or in capsule form or in
gummy form, that could help with pain. So THC, that psychoactive form is going to give you that
psychoactive effect on your brain and a lot of people don't like that. And I tell a story years ago,
when I was in the midst of my cancer, of me taking that as an attempt with my cancer, and I really did
like that. Of course, I never take any drugs or nothing. So it's just, I just don't like take it any
that sound, but I've had people that have been like purists and never put a drug in their body.
And so thankful that they tried THC for their pain because it worked so well. So it is an herb,
so don't feel bad about it. And it is legal. It is what every state, I think it's illegal at every
state now. So that's something we don't legally sell THC because you have to be a distributor,
but there's, you know, in every state, there's different places you could go and buy it and probably
just whatever city. So those are the things that I would think of. Always you want to deal with the
reason why the pain is there. So if it's there because of a space occupied lesion, you have a mass,
then, you know, anything you could do to help relieve, you know, pressure on that mass is going to
be helpful. Don't feel horrible about having to take Tylenol or Advil or something like that,
typically Tylenol or Advil is not going to cause cancer to grow. So if, you know, there can be
negative effects with it, especially if you have sensitivities to it, but don't feel like
you're, you know, going against the natural hypocritical, apocratic oath by taking something
like that, you have to break the pain cycle. So don't feel guilty about that. But those are the
things that I would think of. Other neurological thing that can help with mild pain is the neurological
aspect of stimulating the prefrontal cortex, especially the right prefrontal cortex.
Overrides, there's actually Rubio, I forgot the tract name that actually that actually blocks
the parietal pain response. I can't remember the name of the tract off the top of my head,
but, but you can stimulate the right prefrontal cortex by doing novel activities.
I had a patient, I share this story. I have a patient, we still have the patient, I mean, she started
with us about, go out, eat jeepers. It's going to be going on 20 years ago with rectal cancer,
really bad. And she had such anal pain. We use this technique on her. And so stimulating the
right prefrontal cortex is you do that by using novel activities. That means learning something new
in one of the easiest ways to do that is to start putting together jigsaw puzzles.
That's what I told her to do. All she needed, she couldn't sit down, she'd stand up,
have a jigsaw puzzle at the table and she put it together, a jigsaw puzzle. Now a jigsaw puzzle
is using your, when you are looking at jigsaw puzzle, you're stimulating your right prefrontal cortex
because it's all new. Even if you've done this jigsaw puzzle five times already. So,
because you got a thousand piece puzzle and you're having defined where that goes and you're looking
for where it goes and you have to match colors and this is an outside piece inside piece. Here's
the church, here's the house and you're trying to put this together. It is all right prefrontal exercise.
Learning a new activity. Oh, I'm learning a new song or I'm having to be creative and write a new song
or I'm having to be creative and learn how to use my computer. Those are all right prefrontal
exercises. You'll even think back, you could probably think back and have, having a time of stress
or a time of pain and you had to put your mind on something new because you had to learn something
and you forgot about your pain and you may have thought, oh, because of my mind was busy,
I just forgot about it. No, you're actually stimulating that neural tract and it's blocking the
pain path. So, the neural science is actually identified that track. When you stimulate the right
prefrontal cortex, you're blocking the pain path. So, and again, one of the, you know,
there you can do different crossword puzzles and different things like that, but I think jigsaw
puzzles are one of the easiest ways to do it. And I always tell my brain-based patients if some people
like, I hate jigsaw puzzles. I just absolutely hate doing jigsaw puzzles. Well, if there's an activity
that you hate doing that you probably should do it. It's an indication that you really should do that
activity because that's going to build that neural pathways even more so. So, those are would be
some things you could do to help block pain pathways. And I've had people in severe pain
that that technique has worked for them. Next question, kidney stones symptoms showing up
anything more I could do. So, this person has got kidney stones, may have had kidney stones in the
past. Now, they're getting symptoms of kidney stones. What can they do? I'm using the right lemon juice,
olive oil, plus homeopathic pills. Also, one of your thoughts on sea cucumber. Yeah, give it a try.
There's also a product by herb farm that's called stone breaker. I can't remember the ingredients
in it, but we've had a lot of people that have used that for kidney stones. I'd give, if I had kidney
stones, I'd be trying anything to help with kidney stones. You could, yeah, those are the things
that I would think of. Make sure you're obviously drinking lots of water and trying to flush those.
I've never had a kidney stone, but I've heard there's the most painful thing that a person can go
through. So, I feel for you, we'll definitely be praying for this person with kidney stones extremely
painful. We're talking about pain, you know, the thing that we just talked about on this may help the
pain of a kidney stone. It's not going to help a kidney stone pass, but it may help the pain.
Okay, let's go to the chat and see what questions we have. Hi, Dr. Cutters. I started using my
wife six days ago. After two nights, I started to have what I would describe as stomach ache constantly.
I had also started my cycle during that time. So, some of the pain was consistent with that pain,
but I, but it lingered days past what is usual. So, I don't remember. What's my cancer? Okay.
All right. So, I had also started my cycle, Liger days past. It caused several bowel movements during
these days as well. I also started to have shoulder pain in my left shoulder where I had pain post
surgery due to the gases in my stomach. So, if you had shoulder pain post surgery due to the gases in
your stomach and your left shoulder, I'd highly suggest that's due to your gallbladder.
A gallbladder will refer pain to your left shoulder. So, first of all, I would say, just given this
information here, coffee animals are going to be your friend. You've got to start doing coffee
animals. You are, if the, if you are getting pain post doing the right machine, you're probably detoxing
and it may be getting blocked in your gallbladder. Coffee animals are going to be your friend.
Also, hot packs over your liver. So, getting hot packs over your liver in the next step would be
castor oil packs over your liver with the hot pack over the castor oil pack. Definitely felt off
all around. Yep, you're probably detoxing. I had read that using the rifle caused you to first feel
worse or symptoms before you feel better. It doesn't, maybe, maybe on only about 20% of the time
that really does happen. So, but that's probably what you're feeling. It's really signs of a blocked
gallbladder. Hot packs over your liver, you're going to be kidding your gallbladder that way.
Tricky lots of water, trying to flush out your gallbladder. Even some, some massage under your
right rib cage to try to get your gallbladder moving. That would be also helpful.
Those are the things that I would think of first. Doing multiple coffee animals per day, definitely.
So, that will really help that getting that flow going. That was the only question for the chat, I guess.
So, any other questions? So, those that are new, if you think are thinking of something or
listen to this, like, oh, that sparks a question. Just go ahead and chat it in, or you could unmute
yourself. I can't unmute you, but you could unmute yourself and just talk, speak in a question,
if you're more comfortable with that. Hey, Dr. Connors, it looks like there are some
chat questions out there. I'm not sure why you can't see them. Why? Oh, wait, no wait. Let's see.
Okay, here we go. The Zoom has this new thing here. Okay, to everyone, I have D-Pain
sense December. I use DMSL cream and drops with red light therapy, which helped also right frequency.
Is there a supplement for joint and inflammation for this issue? I can also be, can it also be
caused from detoxing? Well, I wouldn't, if you're asking if D-Pain can be caused from detoxing, I would
say, probably not. Is there a supplement for joint and inflammation? So, your larger joints,
like your knee joint and your hip joint, are fluid fill joints. I mean, most of your joints are fluid
fill joints, but they're going to produce a fluid in that joint capsule. So, there's a capsule
three-dimensionally around these two bones that are coming together to form a joint, and in that
capsule is a fluid, that is joint fluid, and it's produced by the capsule cells. And as we age,
that joint fluid decreases, and that's where our bones can rub a little bit more, be irritated,
you know, when we're walking a lot, or, you know, weight-bearing, especially our bigger weight-bearing
joints. So, what can help us produce more of that joint fluid, because it is the joint fluid,
and then gas within the fluid that gives it a push. You've got millions of little bubbles
within that inside that joint fluid that give the cushion of that joint to protect the two bones
rubbing together. So, there's two things called glucosamine and condroitin that can increase joint
fluid production. Now, it doesn't really help with your finger joints as much, but it helps with
your larger joints, especially the knees, it can be really helpful. So, taking glucosamine and
condroitin, and neither of them are contraindicated for cancer patients, that can help increase joint
fluid production, and millions of people have taken that to help with degenerative arthritis,
which is that loss of joint fluid and some sparing of the bones. So,
condroitin and glucosamine, you can usually get them in products that have both of them
in a product that has both of those in there. Next question, do you have a preference for a sugar
substitute? How about monk fruit? You can use monk fruit. You can use, you want to use things,
I got mute, if you're not muted, if you can mute yourself with very feedback.
You can use honey, you can use maple syrup. Some people have used the sugar alcohols,
and I'm not opposed to using the sugar alcohols if you're using a small amount of it. I mean,
you're typically not buying that as an additive to make something with, but they're maybe in a bar or
something, like a protein bar that you're eating. Oh, is this a rithroid called good for you? That's
a sugar alcohol. It doesn't spike your glucose, so it's good that way, but they're not necessarily
good for you, so you don't want to be taking sugar alcohols all the time. But if you eat that protein bar
every several days, I don't think it's necessarily going to be harmful for you. Some people can have
a greater sensitivity to the sugar alcohols and tend to react to them, but that's really
minor amount number in the population. So they were really big in the adkins type era when
they're adkins bars and all that kind of stuff. We're really big, which were zero-car bars
for dietary purposes and things, people being on the adkins. But people are eating four or five
of those a day. Yes, you're getting way too much sugar alcohols, but if you're eating one or
whatever a couple of days or something, I don't think that's a problem. But in general,
your more natural sugar substitutes are going to be that things that are listed in your binder.
I think we have different things like monk food and people serve with honey and things like that.
Next, is there any rife program to use that will help eliminate glyphosate from my system?
No, there's not. Or say. So there's not a rife frequency that will pull glyphosate out of your
body. Nor is there a rife frequency that will pull mercury out of your body or pull mycotoxins out
of your body. That's not how a frequency from a light source is going to work.
Is there rife frequencies in your program already that will help with your liver detoxification
process? Yes, I put that in everybody's program in your overnight program already.
We've had that question asked, what rife program can I run to help me detoxify?
Well, there isn't a rife detoxification program per say.
Again, the rife machine is best to kill pathogens to stimulate your organs because it works on living
things. To kill cancer cells, it's working on living things. It's not going to pull stuff out of your
body. So that's where you have to use a tool the best way it is. Meaning you're running liver
frequencies. That's in again, what I said, in everybody's overnight program already.
That's really all you can do. So you're stimulating your liver to work better. Remember,
your liver is in your kidney, which those two frequencies, those sets of frequencies are in everybody's
program. It's going to help you with the process of detoxification. Remember, go back to
seven phases of detoxification. Course to really understand how detoxification is in how it works
because I think there's a lot of mythical things about detoxification, like there's some sort of
magic detox that I'm going to do that's going to get rid of XYZ toxin. And I'm going to not have
that in my body anymore. That is just not true. That's not how physiology works. So you have to be
eliminating phase six detoxification. You have to be poopy to the toilet and pee to the toilet.
That's how you're going to ultimately get things out of your body. That and sweating.
So using the sauna is going to help because you're bypassing the gut and the kidneys by using the
sauna. You're sweating. You need things that are being dumped into the small intestine and then moving
to the colon. You want them to stay there and not be reabsorbed in the colon. So you're using a binder.
Have almost everybody on a binder. So there's nothing else you have to do there. So if you're not
having a good bowel movement, at least one every day, you're already toxifying yourself. You're already
behind the eight ball. Well, how do I do that? Well, you start taking magnesium at night. Oh, hello,
let's start doing the coffee animals. So getting into our coffee animals, doing coffee
animals is one of the greatest ways that you can detox because it's going to help you eliminate.
It's going to help your intestinal transit time speedups so that you're not reabsorbing things
dealing with phase five. It's going to help your gall bladder dealing with phase four. It's going to
help your liver dealing with phase one, two, three. So coffee animal is your best overall detoxification tool.
And then you're working on curating to pull things out of the tissue into the blood
and glyphosate are in your tissues and we're trying to get them into the blood. So we can get
them into the liver and the kidneys and get them into the toilet. So look back at that seven
phases of detox to help understand the process. And then we'll, you know, we're going to be on the
right track. Next question, you talked about scalar light therapy. Do you recommend adding
that to rife as stated in the question about scalar today? No, I'm saying that is the rife. So
light therapy is what you're using it already. You're using a Tesla bulb, which is a gas-filled
bulb, which is using light as your healing source versus using a, like a electrical stem. Like
as everybody go into a physical therapist or a car proctor, they put these electrical pads on
your body because your muscles are in spasm and they turn it up and say, okay, is that good enough?
Is that high enough? And it's zapping your back and it's helping relax the muscles. That's electrical
therapy or PEMF device where it's pulsing a electrical frequency. Boom, boom, boom, boom, through
your tissues. These are great to help relax muscles. These are great to help decrease inflammation,
but they're not going to kill cancer. They're not going to kill pathogens. So electrical therapy
isn't going to kill a pathogen because it's a different wave form. Whereas light therapy,
if it's the same frequency of the pathogen, it's going to kill the pathogen. So if you're running,
let's say, let's say I have a virus. Let's say I have COVID, okay, and I'm running the COVID
frequencies. I'm going to be helping my body kill COVID. Let's say I have cancer and I'm going to run,
let's say I have, you know, breast cancer and I'm running the breast cancer frequency. That's going
to help my body kill breast cancer. So because it's a light frequency, tuned into the same frequency
that you're trying to kill. So that's what's scalar. If you're using scalar energy in that definition
of the term, and again, I don't like this early, using that term because it's not really defined
in science. But if we're going to define it that way, which most alternative, the beginning of
the use of that term, that's what it was meant. It's light therapy that can penetrate your tissue.
That's scalar energy. Then that is the correct definition of that term, though because it is
a scientific term, companies have kind of redefined it to sell a product, and I don't like that. So
that's why I just don't use that term. Okay. Any other questions? Somebody there? Yes. Okay. So
no, I see your question. I see cucumber was for prostate cancer. Right. Yes.
So did you cover for your prostate cancer? I have no trouble using that. Rex, if you have that
and want to use that, we have a CQ cover that I tested when I did your cheek swap test. I said I
didn't test, but if you have a different product, it may be better. And if you feel like God's
leading you, by all means, do that. I seek there is no downside to do that to using that.
So it isn't, well, that's why I just say, you know, I don't know if you're here with that first
question answer to us. Can I use other supplements? The only thing I say is just ask. Ask.
That's why. Yeah. Okay. So there's no downside to that. There's no negatives to that.
Okay. Um, I had on the, on the, there's two other programs on the kidney, kidney stones there.
Can you explain that there's one that's like a kidney stimulus and then there's a kidney.
I don't remember what the other one was in the right machine. Are those kind of all the same?
Oh, there's a little different frequencies depending on what you're trying to do. So let's say if
the person has low functioning kidney, so some people have like a 20% function of a kidney, you know,
so then you're running a kidney stimulus program trying to stimulate function of the kidney. So
there's just a little different frequencies in there. Um, so that wouldn't really be, I mean,
you could say, well, couldn't that help a kidney stone because it could help you flush it?
Yeah. You know, so if I had kidney stones that we run in all those programs.
Okay. All right. So it's good. All right. Thank you. Yes.
What's your problem? Go ahead. Yep.
Um, a couple of calls ago, somebody said something about their day program
and you said it was in our book work, but I can't find it in my book work.
So it's not in your book work. It's in your program folder. So, um, let's see, I don't know
who's asking this question. Um, it's hearing. Oh, so it should be in your program. I could look
at your program, but I'm pretty sure that you have a day program in there. So it usually I might
have titled it shorter program. Um, I usually title it shorter day program, but sometimes
I'm thinking of something else and I just title it shorter program or or I just title it day program
in the folder of your overnight sets. So, oh, oh, okay.
of your overnight sets in the right, in your right folder, it'll have Sunday, Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday, Saturday, and then it usually has I put one, two, three, whatever day programs in
there as well. Oh, okay. Okay. Thank you. Okay. Thank you. But I will, I will make a comment about that
because, um, you know, so there's some people that, you know, their cancer is pretty stable and then
they choose during the day, let's say they come home from work and they are sitting in want to use
the knife. Um, they choose during the day to run other comorbidities like like the person who just
mentioned they're having kidney stone issues. So during the day, he's running kidney stone programs
and he might even choose to forego his cancer programs to run kidney stones at night because they
can be awfully painful to get this to pass. Um, so, um, but if the person is, I, I recommend if the
person's cancer is fairly active that they're running those shorter cancer because the day programs
that I put in your folder are cancer programs. So they're not, some people have asked can you put
such and such else in my program with it, but it'll be listed differently. So if it's a shorter day
program, it is a cancer program. So, um, I was wondering what that was. Yeah. So that's a,
that's just a shorter day program for your cancer. Um, and some people ask, do I have to do that? I,
I don't have time to do that. No, no, that's just if you have time run that too because again, the more
frequencies you could hit your cancer with the better chance you're going to have deaths at those
cancer cells. So, um, uh, the biggest mistake that people you make running the right, not my patients,
but I'm talking to other people that go by a right, but she'd somewhere and say it didn't work. It's
because they're, they're not doing it long enough. Plus, they might be using the wrong machine. It's
not even powerful enough to get at it. They're using the wrong frequencies. So nothing's going to work.
But that's it. They had the right machine and the right frequencies. And if they're not getting any
response at all, it doesn't mean everybody's going to get a response, but if they're not getting
any results, but all most commonly, they're not using it long enough. So, um, now that's why I write
them overnight programs. You're getting eight hours in, but I have some people that are really,
really sick. They're basically doing this 24 seven. Um, and then, uh, if you're doing well, you're
doing better, you're maybe running different programs during the day. Okay. Okay. Thank you. You bet.
Okay. Next question. Lots of information about BPC 157 for fast tissue repair and immunity
response. So BP 157 is a peptide. Um, and we've talked about peptides on this before. There is a lot
of information about peptides coming out. That is, uh, you can get that in an injectable form.
And you can now get this in an oral form. Are these good for cancer? Uh, the answer is yes,
said no, you have to be really careful with these peptides for cancer because it does stimulate
growth. Now, depending on the cancer, I've tested people on it and I have some cancer people on
these peptides. Um, uh, and, but them, but it's a minor number. So you do have to be careful with
cancer and using peptides. Uh, am I all for using peptides with other issues that are not cancer
related? Oh, absolutely. So it's a good stimulus for growth and regeneration. But you do have to
be cognizant of you don't want to stimulate excess growth with cancer. So that brings it to another,
you know, forget all the way back to the first comment. Um, you could go be going to a practitioner
that is, let's say, oh, just started using peptides and I see these great results for this and that.
And then you come in with why I have cancer. Well, you should use these peptides. This is really
all but this person. Okay, well, some things that you would do for somebody who has heart issues,
you don't do with cancer. Some things you would do with person with autoimmune issues,
you don't do with cancer. Some things you do with the person with, you know, uh, whatever cancer is
its own ball of wax and, you know, you have to know, you know, there are certain things you don't
want to do with cancer. So, um, just be careful of that. I liked, you know, we for, for, this is,
I think we've been doing these zoom calls for not over nine years now. Um, for probably the first
seven years, nobody used the chat. Everybody just muted themselves and spoke in a question.
And, uh, and then I don't for some strange reason, somebody started using the chat and everybody
used the chat and chatted into question, which is fine too. I'm happy with that. But it was kind
of nice. This is the first time about two years that we had several people in one zoom call that
spoke in the question. I really liked that. That was kind of nice. Um, can, can we check a cheek swab?
I think that's what you're asking. Um, can a cheek swab decide about? So can a cheek swab decide
whether a BP C157 is good. Yes, such a guy you can just send in a cheek swab and we can test for
that. But if you send in a cheek swab, I don't think we've done one for a while. We'll check, we'll
recheck everything. So, all right. Any other questions? All right. I think we'll wrap up tonight.
Thanks so much for everybody being on. Uh, have a blessed rest of the week.
Have any sort of emergency make sure you give us a holler. Remember we have the lower fees.
Um, for all our members now too. Um, so I love talking to you. I really liked that you guys
chatted and you spoke in the questions. That was more fun. All right. Have a great day. Bye-bye.